how's it going everybody promise after
this clip you will go over and watch the
full podcast on life reacts I'll see you
guys over there don't forget to check it
out on Spotify as well so a lot of
people don't know that the encounter
where you blew up talking to uthman they
don't know that you actually had a few
encounters with him before that yeah so
let's talk about the encounters before
you decided to go to utman with your own
camera before God logic huh mhm yeah uh
so man so I actually was doing Facebook
lives at the time
[Laughter]
and how many people was in them live man
man it would fluctuate between 35 to 12
you know then I start I stopped seeing
35 and was only seeing 12 15 yeah you
know
um but yeah it was uh it was fun though
it was it was a fun time I'll tell you
that yeah but yeah so I was doing that
and um and I was part of a lot of
different Facebook groups and all like
debate Facebook groups Muslim and
Christian debates and dialogues and
stuff right and I just wanted uh I
really wanted to do some in-person stuff
I was like man is there is there a a
Muslim do they do this Muslim booths and
you know that type of outside da IRL da
I didn't know and
so um lo and behold I shakman an
interview with shakman popped up um on a
video or whatever and I was like I was
like man where is this and he said he
was in San Diego at Bboy Park yeah I was
like oh say less right up the street
yeah that's at the time that was 3 hours
away from me oh wow that that ain't
right but that was dedication though
yeah for sure so I was excited I was
like oh he's in Cali he's just hours
away oh I'm I'm going up there right so
so was there a schedule or did you know
or you was just like I'mma just see if
dude up here um I knew that I knew that
he was there on um I think Sunday okay
or the weekend okay it was the weekend
that it was mentioned
so so yeah so uh I went up there you
know we went to San Diego was me it was
my
mom um and uh we saw different booths
there and everything like that they told
us yeah you know Christians set up here
Muslims set up there I'm like all right
say l so stayed the weekend and uh went
to the booth that Sunday now it was
funny because you know I'm I'm un
assuming I don't look like really much
and so they had a booth they out there
handing handing out their tracks I'm
walking by they rushed me do you do you
know about Islam wow what do you believe
you're a Christian wow yeah yeah I'm a
Christian you're like oh why you
Christian why why don't you believe ISL
yeah oh oh you I'm glad you
asked I'm glad you asked so I'm talking
to him and for and and he can't really
like you know uh really handle me umman
pulls up you know so Usman comes a
little later and then he's like here's
here's our guy you should talk to him
and so then we I started talking to
utman now the conversation's on his
channel but um part of it is not like
the so we've talked about the Islamic
dilemma first and that entire part of
the conversation is cut wow and the rest
is just about Bible contradictions and
stuff wow so yeah so he put promise
after this clip you will go over and
watch the full podcast on life reacts
I'll see you guys over there don't
forget to check it out on Spotify as
well